foreign
ER okay I was thinking the other day
about compasses Gotta Love a compass you
know they make great circles and they
got a great little stabby thing on the
end you could poke people in the butt
when you're in the hallway at school
they make that noise it's wonderful I
love compasses
so you were carrying instruments of math
destruction yes
um no no it's not that Compass I'm
talking about I'm talking about the kind
that where you find your way okay all
right and if that's what you did with
your compass I did that's this damn poke
people in their ass that's like that's
why I did not become an astrophysicist
it's
a math hazard
Okay so we've known for a while that
Earth has a magnetic field okay and
there was lodestone which is a naturally
occurring variant of iron that is
basically a magnet and the people just
experimenting with it playing with it
would notice that it aligns
without anybody touching it we would
ultimately perfect this into a compass
so there's a little needle with an N on
it
and that little needle
Points North every time a couple of
facts just to consider
okay in magnetism
Opposites attract
correct and in love
okay well Opposites attract
and the North Pole of the needle of my
compass
Points North
that means Earth's South magnetic pole
is north
just hang on for a second here
yeah because
that one might have hurt a little bit
it hurts just a little bit you don't
understand things if I have a magnet
with the North and South Pole and I
bring a compass near the magnet a second
here
so you're saying the needle itself
is magnetized North
and it Points North
which means it's finding the South Pole
of Earth's north
if you take it up to any other magnet
there's a north and a South Pole bring
the compass near it
that North Pole is going to point to the
of the mat of the needle is going to
point to the South Pole of that point to
the South yes because Opposites Attract
right absolutely okay I got you that's
going to point this because that's what
attracts it okay so right therefore
Earth South magnetic pole is in the
North
I gotcha and that still hurts
okay well let's keep going
all right uh the soft magnetic pole
which is in the north which is in the
north does not align
with Earth's geographic pole where Santa
Claus is it does not align they're not
in the same place
okay okay
when I was growing up
the north magnetic pole which contains
the South Pole right so let's just still
call it the North because it's easier
that Pole right
was in Northern Canada
so if you were south of that pole your
compass would basically Point North but
if you're north of that pole between our
magnetic pole and the geographic pole
your compass would point due south
geographically South
and if you're anywhere to the side it
would bend it inward So Good Boy Scout
books would give the correction
for where actual because you know at the
end give a where the magnetic pole
is you care where Santa Claus is right
the geography is what you care about not
the magnetism there's nothing for you at
the north magnetic pole
we don't want Santa to be a Canadian
that's a disaster you know so you want a
truck okay
oh
so the only Canadian joke I know is when
they're learning how to spell Canada and
what we just we think uh C and D
that spells it uh it's CA and and
see that's how the A's got him
that's how the A's got into the spelling
okay you hadn't heard that one that's
how they that's how they end up spelling
yeah all right so uh they would give
correction so if you knew what latitude
you were on Earth what longitude you
were and your latitude you know how to
correct the angle for it all right right
so
here's my point
the north magnetic pole
is on a mission
it is moving
in fact it moves a little less than a
mile per week
that's a lot yes yes
30 to 50 miles per year
due north
since my childhood
okay wow
so I'm an old fart so over the last 60
years there it is it started like in the
in Middle Canada somewhere and it
started going north 50
30 to 50 miles per month okay
so times a year at 500 miles a year what
is that do I do that right 500 miles a
year
due north right now
it is passing the North Pole
on route to Siberia
holy crap yes
so your compass has never been more
accurate before
because it's by it's coming along the
left side of the North Pole uh so it's
close to the North Pole north geographic
North Pole then it then it's ever been
in like recorded history
okay
and so it's gonna it's gonna go on its
way over to Siberia
or which has iron in it that's molten
the movement of that electrically
conducting material such as iron right
will induce a magnetic field that'll
take over the whole planet that'll be
manifest across the planet nice so but
that is if it's the fact that things are
moving means it's not perfectly coupled
to the rest of the planet
so the core can rotate at a slightly
different rate than the whole planet
does and it could sort of process back
in it can do things and right now what
it's doing is it's it's torquing its
North Pole which is really the South
Pole out of Canada by the North Pole and
it's on route to making a beeline for
Siberia
now did you say it's twerking it's well
I didn't know was that what I heard
so strange I mean I I don't I don't
blame anybody for trying to make a
living even in magnetic field I'm just
saying
yeah it's not the words should be more
familiar than it is but it's torque yeah
the auto mechanics know the word torque
but no one else and physicists but
nobody else does a twerking is you you
grab onto something and set it to rotate
or not uh so it's torquing is a force
that instead of putting something into
straight motion puts it into rotational
motion that's a torque okay it's a cool
word
t-o-r-q-u-u-e okay yeah yeah so this is
what's going on with the magnetic field
I just thought I'd update you on that
that's pretty cool actually yeah and
there's no requirement that the magnetic
field exactly align with the geography
in fact it makes sense that it wouldn't
because like you said it's you know the
the core is spinning
inside of you know this kind of liquid
you know right exactly exactly it's all
fluid it's all it's fluid so is it some
coupling but it's not tight coupling so
right yeah it's so it's wandering it's
wandering and so
so by the way planets that have solid
cores don't have magnetic fields right
so the Moon is solid all the way through
no magnetic field we think Mars is solid
all the way through it's got hardly any
barely any magnetic field so but Earth
we know has an active core and by the
way there are stars in the universe
neutron stars that have magnetic fields
that if the magnetic field is steeply
angled
to the rotation axis that means when the
thing rotates it swings past your field
of view
the North Pole or whatever it's supposed
like that
and in so doing it can accelerate
particles and give off radio waves
but these radio waves will pulse past
your field of view
ah these dead stars so we call these
Stars
pulsars yes get out of here that's
amazing a pulsar is a magnetic neutron
star with a magnetic field axis is
tipped so that as it rotates it swings
it past your field of view so nothing is
actually pulsing right it's just it's
like a lighthouse effect right yeah
that's so cool perfect the way the
lighthouse yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now
when I was a kid a pulsar was a watch
that's all we knew but they got their
word from us just so you know we can we
got it first we got there first okay and
we got there first with a whole lot of
vocabulary like anti-matter that's us
first okay come on that was Star Trek
you know that from Star Trek you know
you stole that from Star Trek and half
the stuff that that they didn't steal
they made up and doesn't exist like
dilithium crystals the entire dilithium
Crystal converter assembly is fused no
chance of
yeah there's there's lithium but there's
no dialysis no dyeless and there's
definitely no dilithium crystals there's
flux
and there's a capacitor
but there's no flux capacity
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyhow I I so and this magnetic field oh
by the way there are times where the
where our magnetic field has flipped
okay and the people read about this and
they worry that when they say oh the
access is going to flip they think it's
like a physical axis right and they're
worried that that'll be the end of the
world but no the magnetic axis what will
happen is the Dynamo slows down dies
dies it it fades then the magnetic field
disappears right and then it reappears
but flipped from what it was before
so in that future
right the actual Magnetic North Pole
will be in the north and Compasses will
then all Point South
when that happens oh by the way you know
something that happens to the Sun every
11 years
that's cool because the sun rotates once
once a month okay that's pretty fast for
something a million times larger than
the earth and so it has a magnetic field
that magnetic field
um uh slowly dissipates goes away comes
back and resets itself pointing the
other direction and all sunspots come in
pairs and the Sunspot pair is a positive
and negative of a magnetic field
so magnetism is everywhere
it's very cool
that is more than cool
and when the sun's magnetic field is
getting weaker and weaker and before it
flips all the sun's about to go away
it's pretty wild so this magnetic thing
it's it's not just uh I mean it's it's
an active Force operating on this world
and others excellent just thought I'd
tell you I love it all right this was a
good one okay
this was a good one okay
if you happen to still have one of those
bar magnets take a string with a thin
thread tie it exactly in the middle and
just dangle it there and it will align
it you don't it doesn't have to be
inside of a compass vessel it'll just
it'll it's fine magnetic north right now
it's pretty close to Santa
nice yeah there you go all right dude
it's been another explainer this one on
the compass
and what what do they call the thing
below the compass that it spins on
um I'm gonna say uh the the pad the
compass rose the what the compass rose
you never heard that no I never heard
that you never heard that because
because every direction of the compass
has a little arrow on it right because
it looks like a flower and they called
the compass rose that's beautiful
it sounds like a country music act
hi y'all we're compass rose
what's up
and one last thing before we call it
quits at Grand Central
terminal yes New York City yes
in the subway yep
on the floor okay
is a compass rose
oh yeah that's right now there's no
Compass no there's nothing there's no
needle on it but there's no you know
that is pointing the north that's real
on the geography of the world that's
right and so and that's in the subway so
it's just it's getting ready inlaid into
the floor inlaid into the floor yeah
yeah last time last I checked it was
there there's been a lot of Subway
yeah they've redone everything there now
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and plus you
never know what the rats are going to do
sometimes they're just like we're gonna
redecorate we're sorry we're tired of
looking at this and this paint was tasty
let me lick it off
hey
you brought some pizza with you I'll
meet you at the compass rose
okay for those who are aren't getting it
there was a famous viral video called
the pizza rat and it was a rat trying to
drag A Slice of New York Pizza up the
steps to exit the platform with this
pizza
oh God help me all right
there's been another Star Talk explainer
uh this one on the compass and the
compass rose with Chuck always good to
have you man wow he's a pleasure Neil
deGrasse Tyson here bidding you to keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]